[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute dieses
chaka terim bord und falls ihr euch
wundert warum meine nase so ein bisschen
gewachsen ist ich werde gleich nochmal
den hamza damit trinken aber es riecht
so schlimm da drin das ist jetzt mal
ganz kurz wieder abnehmen kommentar wir
machen dieses heftige halloween tag
attribut jetzt erstmal nicht frage für
alle die es noch nicht gehört und ich
habe es auch erst vor ein paar monaten
das erste mal gesehen dass es so was
gibt ich habe auch schon mal eins
gemacht hat meine freundin da waren das
könnt ihr euch gerne mal ein blenden das
waren eher so ja viel viel kleiner und
ganz andere sachen drauf ist kohle ist
so ein board ist so wie diese neue
abwandlung von einem fingerfood buffet
wird ich jetzt einfach mal sagen wenn
man hat alles eng beieinander entwaffnen
bord oder auf einem großen teller und
das kann sowohl süß als auch herzhaft
sein ich hab das auch genau so gemacht
hier sind süße sachen dort im herzhafte
sachen und das cool ist jeder kann sich
einfach bedienen und das nehmen was man
möchte und ich persönlich finde auch ist
alles ein bisschen einfacher mann kennt
einfacher gestalten als so ein
fingerfood buffet weil dann hat man ja
bei einem fingerfood büfett alles so
einzeln stehen rey anrei und so weiter
und da muss man halt immer so viel auch
selbst machen damit das halt nach was
aussieht hier habe ich aber auch viele
fertige sachen schon und die kunst ist
es einfach das alles ansehen nicht zu
präsentieren aber ich habe auch vieles
selbst gemacht und das zeige ich euch
jetzt mal im schnelldurchlauf ich starte
mit diesem know me in würstchen und
dafür habe ich mir einfach tiefgekühlten
blätterteig aufgetaut circa zehn minuten
dann in feine streifen geschnitten und
einmal um die würstchen herum gewickelt
das ganze dann bei 220 grad ober und
unterhitze für so circa 18 bis 22
minuten bis sie goldbraun werden in dem
backofen gegeben und anschließend ja
einfach die augen noch drauf machen aber
dass wir dann noch nachher
[Musik]
danach habe ich diese windbeutel monster
gemacht und dafür ganz einfach
zartbitter kuvertüre fein hacken ich
habe dann in die mikrowelle gegeben 600
watt also nicht so hoch stellen und hat
es ungefähr zweieinhalb minuten gedauert
immer wieder umrühren und sobald die
kuvertüre geschmolzen ist die windbeutel
rhein geben und das ganze auf dem
backpapier geben und da könnte dann
augen dazu geben gerne ungleichmäßig x 4
x 5 pa streusel und dann sind sie auch
schon fertig
[Musik]
bretzel gehören für mich sowieso oft das
plakat report das habe ich fast direkt
eingekauft aber ich fand sie so ein
bisschen langweilig und habe dann
einfach nur cape in verschiedenen farben
genommen und quasi einfach drauf
gedrosselt damit einfach so ein bisschen
hübscher aussieht
[Musik]
für diese geister habe ich epo genommen
ich weiß die türken unter euch kennen
sie jetzt wahrscheinlich ist diese
schaumstoff den keks dran und da einfach
nur ein gesicht aufzeichnen ich habe
dafür meinen schwarzen cape verwendet
[Musik]
dann habe ich hier noch so babybel
kürbisgesichter dafür nehmt euch einfach
ein sehr scharfes messer oder skalpell
und schnitzt das ganz einfach ein das
geht so war schnell
[Musik]
so jetzt geht es ans eingemachte
endlich ich habe mir hier so ein bord
geholt sie schon ziemlich groß ist
eigentlich ist es um bord was ich für
fotos benutzt wir können natürlich auch
kleinere benutzen oder wenn eine
riesen-party habt dann verteilt es gerne
komplett auf den tisch und ich fange
jetzt einfach mal an das ganze so ein
bisschen zu drapieren darum geht es ja
im endeffekt wie ich gerade schon
erklärt habt ihr könnt euch jetzt
überlegen mischte süß und herzhaft
komplett macht in einer ecke nur süß in
einer nur herzhaft ich würde sagen ich
gucke einfach mal nach gefühl ich starte
mit was große da nämlich zuallererst
beispiel müssen wir fordern von der
auswahl gerade dann nämlich zuallererst
chips denn die haben viel diesen groß
deren volumen die neben schon ganz viel
von bord beck und deswegen kann ich
damit an
das sind so dass und wasabi chips im
grünen deswegen habe ich hauptsächlich
gekauft
wie lege ich jetzt schon mal die einen
angriff
so jetzt kommen die top kekse also diese
ganzen cracker und so funktionieren sehr
gut kleiner fun fact auf sie ist talk
sour cream und an ian und ich war damals
vor zehn jahren bei der marktforschung
mit dabei da existiert irgendwo noch ein
video von mir endlich das probiert es
nun gar nicht auf dem markt war und ich
fand es damals schon lecker und
das coole ist bei diesem check cuturi
bord könnt ihr so richtig diese cracker
jetzt in schlangenlinien drapieren und
das finde ich macht schon mal so richtig
aus
[Musik]
jetzt kommen die büdchen zum einsatz so
hier sind meine würstchen und da ich
jetzt so viel ab jetzt zwölf stück
insgesamt kann ich sowohl in der einen
ecke als auch zwischendrin noch welche
mit verbauen ich packe es hier neben den
topten ein paar hin und den fehlen
übrigens noch augen das mache ich jetzt
direkt da könnte entweder zucker augen
nehmen fast immer nicht ganz so oder
ihnen einfach um even scheiben ich bin
zu dem entschluss gekommen dass oliven
doch nicht so gut aussehe weil die sind
sehr groß daher nehme ich jetzt doch
zucker augen ist so fragwürdige kombi
aber es ist ja auch halloween da gibt
nämlich einfach ein bisschen ketchup als
kleber und gibt es zwei zucker augen ich
habe ja auch extra platz dafür gelassen
quasi in die mitte
so jetzt die oliven was zur liebe
natürlich auch immer ganz gut passt sie
mit verschiedene käsesorten da habe ich
kam an der ich habe weichkäse hartkäse
da hab ich eigentlich alle möglichen
varianten geholter käse ist ja auch so
wenn man erwachsen ist ich fühle mich
noch nicht so erwachsen aber wenn man
erwachsen ist übrigens auch ein dessert
wusstet ihr dass so die oliven habe ich
jetzt hier da bieten sich so diese
sorten an die ihr dann auch seine stück
bekommen also ich hier zum beispiel und
dann kann man einfach wie beim kuchen so
stück herausschneiden
[Musik]
und jetzt solltet ihr auch immer so ein
bisschen darauf achten dass sie so ein
farbspiel habt also nicht sehr viel
brown auf einer stelle nicht ganz viel
weiß immer so sondern nehme sie die
babywelt und packte hier schon mal
direkt dazwischen und dieser farbklecks
wirkt schon wieder richtig auch richtig
band wollte ich noch etwas sagen aber
das wirkt so ist sie halt interessanter
aus wenn ihr viele verschiedene farben
miteinander kombiniert so typisch für
halloween sind diese kürbisse und da
habe ich mir überlegt nehme ich jetzt
einfach ein bisschen popcorn ich habe
jetzt hier oben am und nicht so eine
große öffnung aber ich kann ihn ja hier
einfach relativ mittig drapieren und
hinten raus das popcorn raus laufen
lassen was haben wir denn hier die profi
cacau und trocken sein
wir sind ja auch ein bisschen dunkler
noch nicht ganz so weit
zwischendurch müssen auch mal essen
und zum probieren das ist auch gut
schnee von gestern
als nächstes habe ich hier rinder salami
dann nehmt euch einfach so eine scheibe
einmal hier so in der hälfte und dann
nochmal knicken und dann macht er immer
so weiter und wichtig ist dass ihr dann
nicht so die gleiche richtung nimmt
sondern in dem gegen gesetzte richtung
so ein bisschen drapiert dann habt ihr
nämlich schon mal so eine richtig
richtig schöne linie und da könnt ihr
auch so ein richtig schön lange strang
ziehen ich bleibe hier oben in der sehr
herzhaften ecke wort die würstchen sind
und genau liegt das dann einfach so
dahin
[Musik]
also solange sachen wie zum beispiel
jetzt hier immer diese die strings jetzt
kind geliebt und diese snack werden die
passen auch mal ganz gut die könnte
schön an den rändern drapieren wie oft
hab ich das wort therapieren gesagt in
diesem video das ist die süße ecke die
kommen ja die pack ich hierhin und jetzt
kommen natürlich die sache nicht
vorbereitet habe gleich noch trauben und
die sachen nicht vorbereitet habe die
praktisch alle zehn die süße ecke also
einmal diese windbeutel monster dann
merkt man auch okay da wird es langsam
süß die brezeln und
anschließend einfach nur noch die lücken
füllen es muss richtig voll aussehen es
darf nicht so rüberkommen als er hätte
man nicht genug genug sachen da gehabt
daher die lücken noch mal füllen mit
müssen da könnte der wahlliste nehmen
oder cashewkerne oder diese umwandelten
und einfach alles was sie nur so finden
könnt
[Musik]
wird heftig aus
doch das schreckt mich jetzt ein super
das war zu viel sagt
okay war ist es riecht so dass plastik
aber
ganz
und gar hansa wie findest du es was wir
bloß ein eindruck heftig heftig hektar
man in so ein spiel haben mit freunden
okay vielleicht auch einige nennen so
ist das wahrscheinlich schon so 678
personen zehn personen dann also zehn
personen ist eugen ja als erstes weg
koller films ja auch eher so dass du zum
snacken gedacht das kann ich jetzt ist
was du jetzt geht alles andere ist ja
verkauft
also muss ich so sagen was du weißt was
ich niemals essen würde ist das hier
gemachten käse käse ich mache was ich
auch gemacht aber das rezept sehen wenn
diese monster gemacht da sind einfach
das sind tiefgekühlte windbeutel das ist
dann vorerst nur der name sozialen david
villa sondern aus geschichten cool ich
habe das
jetzt wollte ich bin froh wie bei extrem
ja sonst und ich hab ich
habe ich überwunden die zu kaufen ja das
war schon okay ich will es jetzt
versprochen
hallo
rudi schrift es so wie
heute uns etwas süßes geben dürft ihr
gerne weiterleben oha
also kann als jurist arbeiten würden ja
dann hast du
ich könnte mir jetzt mal ein bisschen
was haben wir denn hier schön dass ein
cracker cottbus einfach so überall hin
greifen wo man gerade lust hat ich
find's cool ich war ja dann später sagen
wann fängt er mit herz sondern das ist
schon in den ferien ja dann will ich mal
sagen ich hoffe das video durchgefallen
ist man ein ganz anderes videos bringen
noch ein zusatz video dieser woche und
in nächster zeit gibt es auch mal drei
videos die woche von uns ich wünsche
euch es noch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen bis zum nächsten
doch zu sagen du sowas
[Musik]